[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'd like to welcome you all to the
no apologies
[Music]
um
okay
thank you for coming along
um
um funnily enough it was while the ndta
were doing their safety
proposals
um
is
a cycle way um there before it connects
with the 50
speed zone so the fact that our
walkway cycleway spans
and um obviously with the wheels
um
um obviously some of it doesn't follow
the existing
road but um are we certain that all that
what might be shown on a cadastral plan
is paper road is actually in
paper road and not being amalgamated
into
the ownership of adjacent properties
in relation to that and it's clearly
from what i understand is
um
it's kind of someone's driveway at the
moment
[Music]
um
is
or something
an issue to speak with them and have
access across that driveway
because either way if you're on stage
too
um
of um we're going to
carry on talking about cycling and
walking
which is good
is
um 25 years
one of the things that come out in the
newspapers the local papers
are prior to lockdown 4 for covert
was has anyone got any suggestions that
may help to get some people into the
town to spend money
and go to our shops and
do those things so i thought about it
and
in 2016 i did the christchurch 360 walk
which is a
160k walk
so it's a decent day's walk or you can
split it into many
different individual ones as you as you
may like from there
um we put it all down we've got a
interesting enough
what we call a standard walking trail
and a wet grass
winter winter option and the reason we
put that in is
that some of the areas where we're
walking around the squirting
around kaiapoi the grass can be fairly
long and wet and
i know the mowing round most of it is
very good even this time of year but
the other the wet trail or the wet grass
or the winter one is
basically on um
here so we we believe it will bring
people into the town i've talked to
one or two retailers in the town about
it and they were quite enthusiastic and
a couple of professional people that
were
interested in it too thought it could be
a good thing
the christchurch one has been supported
by um
environment canterbury and
[Music]
signs up getting some brochures like
this these are the ones i put out by the
360 trail and this just gives you the
what's basically
written into here just an aversion
obviously that's a lot longer because
it's eight days
but um yeah i i think it's something
that would get people into the towns
what we found over covered was the
amount of people out walking
is amazing and i think we've got more
people
level four we walked every day there was
through there two wet was two weird days
we walked on those we actually did 240
k's
in those 30 days so we averaged eight
cases a day
and this is how we got this down to
written here so
there's any is
um
is
but we believe that all of the areas
that we've mapped out
are you know able to be accessed by the
public
um
and things
whether the council or the community
board wants to take it further whether
it's just a case of putting
the notes on the information center that
people can print it off themselves or
put it as a proper brochure
is the christchurch 360 trail was
the brainchild of colin merk the
botanist
very clever man he travels the world
doing
presentations on botany and then
you don't have to worry that that was
just might have been cheeky but the
kayak
360 walking trail i think will get
people out from christchurch i know that
from the walking group
i know people from walking groups
[Music]
um
if the weather changes or somebody gets
tired or or whatever or
frames an ankle in most places you can
get back to the center
where your car is in a very short time
so that's one of the
the retailers
thanks
um
is
that is some of the trails especially on
the wheatgrass winter option
if the bikes are on that too often it's
just going to go to mud
and
us are bikers um um
or don't know the full background of it
so if it was
to be taken up by the trail people and
then they could probably do some quite
good interesting facts
on some of those areas how they
originated
um
a little bit more interesting
and for those that because this
um
congratulations on the work that you've
done are there any elements
that would be suitable for mobility
scooters i've been
asked about mobility
you're talking about styles
good evening and i hope i'm not
repeating myself too much for
many of you here tonight this is my
third
the fourth board
um
so as part of this um had a bit of a
look at supply and demand
so what supply got off and looked at
available and suitable land for
cemeteries in our district
we looked at the changing demographics
of our community
and the changing needs across
different religions and people who
perhaps want to do things like that are
concerned
we've also had a wee look at the
reservation
review the ministry of health thought it
was
justifiable to ask council to take over
any failing symmetries or symmetries
where the trustees no longer want to
manage these symmetries
we suggested that that was all right on
one level
but we needed some sort of process
because at the end of the day there was
a cost to our ratepayers
and whether our ratepayers could
reasonably be expected to carry that
cost
was something else again we also looked
at the issue of pet
law cemeteries originally looked at the
burial information act they had quite a
push from
local territorial authorities
and they decided
of the burial
now secondary to the strategy which is
your overarching
document will be a cemetery policy
we've started planning for that already
and that will give the
way we manage our symmetries on a
day-to-day basis the rules and
regulations
will be the policy
the draft strategy is proposed to go out
for public consultation
on the 7th of august a report and a copy
of that draft will go to council
on the 4th of august so what i'm asking
i imagine that cremation's far more
popular these days
um
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
a b c d
e
7.3
yes
if you have any
um
providers
is
um
what happened
however this is a significant event and
the regeneration of what's happened in
the last 10 years
so it's never going
and i think it's extremely important
given
the involvement of the community board
both in regeneration
and their involvement with the community
in the earthquake itself
right through that whole ten years and i
know that every one of us around this
table still delivered every day
that i think is absolutely important
that we are part of this event
and one of the big ways
we've been through
about the um career visitor strategy the
first workshop
is on the 22nd from the email that i
received
jackie will be representing the board
um
or any questions
thank you
um
has been overwhelmingly
as we all know um
duncan and chris came to us with a
with a proposal of how we're going to
manage it and
after going around in circles for about
20 minutes
basically
who wants to give up their moorings at
what price do they want to give up the
three moorings in the river
do they want to come to the piles what
do they want to pay for the piles
do they want ownership are we going to
lease
um
and all those sort of things
[Music]
um
the passchendaele trust is
meeting in wellington uh thursday and
friday a
rather weird experience
but however and was addressed
by quite a few politicians who
that's going to go and what is going to
do they made it very clear
that um
and how long that takes then we'll
see how long it takes um but it but
something is definitely going to happen
you know there is
760 million interestingly enough
uh it's already 700.
it's already lost
um
made it very clear that it is
[Music]
that was pretty interesting in itself
around where that was going and what it
was doing we also met
with um
um
and a new uh a new president
a new vice president and also a uh
um
uh
is
no the other side of um river um
um webinars
which were free and they were quite
interesting
the first one was road to zero which is
a shift
from the safer journeys approach that
the previous government
um
investment decision making framework
and uh i decided it was probably more
for the staff than for me but it was
interesting
the criteria when territorial
authorities apply for funding
um between
travel times
um
bill
lined up to um in it but it's going to
last for two years
um
so we have a plan um
which i understand
and briefings
to go to
um
the interesting
character meeting that we had for the
cycle way
um
see obelisks
is
uh in terms of funding we're trying to
get
more different funding models through
the food forest so on the 22nd of august
we're
holding our first ever paid foreign
on the 17th of september
as well in terms of funding following on
really from neville in terms of funding
i've been part of meetings that relate
to the community
food community food security foods
and that's for buildings
um
walked
put on facebook
that would be good moving on
thank you everybody out now there are
two things